hey man you want to hear a funny story
it's a
little bit of a side note but i can
segue into this because i got this
membership set up on the channel but the
ghost of nicholas nolte
now i don't know if you remember who
this guy is but i ran into him at a gas
station
in l.a last year
dude i was putting gas in the rental
that i had it was with a friend of mine
down there and my kid
and i'm in the gas station i hear this
heavy breathing and i swear to god just
like in the picture there where you see
him in that avatar he looked exactly
like that hair was all [ __ ] up
breathing heavily and he was a total
train wreck and i walked outside i
wanted to see what he was driving like
i'm thinking he's going to drive
something nice
he had this uh old ass volvo um i can't
remember what they're called but they're
these like
hatchbacks it's kind of like a honda
civic hatchback but it's a volvo version
and the car was full of [ __ ] like the
only place there was no garbage in the
car was where he was sitting
i was i was disappointed because i
thought he was great in that movie with
steven seagal anyway
[Laughter]
wow
you